at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start
shaking can I ask you a personal
question
[Music]
I'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal endoskeleton this podcast is
brought to you by me undies which I'm
wearing right now have you ever wanted
to be as powerful as a mullet wearing
ninja from the 80s or a sleek as a black
panther in the Amazon of course you have
and that is where my undies comes in I
have spent the last year wearing
underwear from these guys 24/7 and they
are the softest most comfortable most
colorful underwear I have ever owned and
it says here in the copy they want a
seasonality hook and this is quote the
summer and fall are the perfect time to
update your underwear drawer
end quote now I don't know why the
summer and fall are specifically true
for that but I would say this that when
you look in your underwear drawer in
your underwear wall very often you'll
see some that are a little ragged
you know the bands are just a little
loose they tend to Sag where they
shouldn't sag that's disgusting
the undies are designed in LA and made
from sustainably sourced micro Modell a
fabric three times softer than cotton
even better
mune Deus has three different
subscription plans so you'll never get
bored with the ever-changing selection
and it includes free shipping there are
many reasons that me Andes has sold more
than five million pairs to date if you
don't love your first pair they'll give
you a new pair or a refund so to get 20%
off your first pair plus free shipping
go to me undies comm forward slash to
him that's me undies comm forward slash
Tim they're also undies for the ladies
not just dudes and lots of hot pics so
check it out Mia news comm forward slash
tip
this episode is brought to you by
99designs I've used 99designs for ages
since even before podcasting was the
thing and I've used them for all sorts
of graphic design needs they are fast
and they are convenient whether you need
a logo website book cover or anything
else I've done competitions for instance
for covers related to the 4-hour body
99designs
makes great design accessible to
everyone and it makes the process so
much easier and I use them recently for
artwork and illustrations inside of my
cow of Seneca set of books so this is a
collection of stoic writing and modern
interviews and so on so for the Tao of
Seneca I decided to use their one-to-one
project service in this case you invite
a specific designer to your project
agree on a price and then work together
until you're satisfied and the artwork
just blew my mind you have to check it
out I kid you not so you can check out
some of the artwork from Toph Seneca as
well as some artwork and logos and so on
that your fellow listeners have had made
at 99designs dot-com forward slash Tim
that's 99designs com forward slash Tim I
really suggest you check it out and
right now you guys can receive a free
$99 upgrade on your first project this
gets you I think a hundred and thirty
percent more submission so people who
want to work with you and give you first
drafts of what you're looking for
to access your free design please visit
99designs dot-com forward slash Tim and
click the link on the landing page
that's 99designs
dot-com forward slash Tim
[Music]
hello ladies and germs welcome back to
the Tim Ferriss show this is Tim Ferriss
and if you've listened to the podcast
before you know it is my job to tease
out the habits routines tactics and
breakfasts or lack thereof of
world-class performers I really dig into
the Nitty Gritty of what you can apply
and this episode is a special episode of
the Tim Ferriss radio hour normally I
speak with one guest in long interviews
but the Tim Ferriss Radio Hour is
thematic so I will look at say
meditation or I will look at failure or
I will look at how people handle a
specific problem or opportunity and then
pull highlights from my conversations
with multiple guests in this particular
episode and went in search of morning
routines morning routines are very
important to me for a lot of reasons now
routine may sound boring but I encourage
you to keep in mind that the quote of WH
Auden which is quote routine in an
intelligent man which could be person of
course is a sign of ambition now why
would that be the case and we're gonna
come back to why that it's the case even
when I get to my own personal example
but first let me give you an idea of who
were going to chat with in this episode
i talked to Jocko willing a legend in
the special operations world and former
US Navy SEAL commander he's also black
belt and Brazilian Jujitsu weighs more
than 200 pounds and can do 60 plus
strict pull-ups
here's Jocko when I wake up in the
morning I'm thinking about the enemy
what can I do to be ready for that
moment which is coming then best-selling
author Seth Godin discusses the
importance that diet plays in the
structure of his day well if there's a
laptop or I'm not unconscious I'm at
work I also interview Academy
award-winning actor and Grammy
award-winning musician Jamie Foxx to ask
him about the first 60 minutes of his
day well I got a home retirement he
played cane and minister Society and he
I cut one how is he always in shape he's
his mom trying to tell you to pull up
bars everything and then Scott Adams
creator of Dilbert shares how he begins
today and discusses the six dimensions
of humor and there's a prize
once you clear your mind you have to
flood it you may use different words for
this but I know you do it this is the
Tim Ferriss Radio Hour on creating your
ideal morning routine so I mentioned
earlier that and this is a quote of
course that routine in the intelligent
person is a sign of ambition and that is
the case because at least from my
perspective your morning should have a
predictable and scripted boot up a
sequence what does that mean that means
that you have an algorithm a set of
steps that produce an optimal day for
you more often than not and that is
dictated in the first 60 to 90 minutes
of your day so it might be as simple as
say making your bed in the morning
look up McRaven making your bed for an
interesting video and commencement
speech all about this it could include
journaling could include any number of
things and by putting those particular
steps on autopilot having that boot up
sequence you can serve your cognitive
calories for the things that matter most
meaning rather than deciding what you're
gonna have for breakfast what type of
toothpaste you're going to use where
you're gonna sit on the toilet or
whatever it might be you are sparing
yourself that cognitive burden so that
you can apply your energy where your
unique strengths can best be applied
later and I've heard it said before and
I do believe that if you win the morning
you win the day so in my case what are
some of the non-negotiables of my
mornings and I've written about this in
tools of titans I've talked about it
elsewhere
it varies very mildly from week to week
from month to month but right now some
of the non-negotiables are wake up prime
state this is per Tony Robbins so I jump
in a cold pool it could be a cold shower
come out I do
20 minutes of transcendental meditation
which could also be for instance
headspace or some type of guided
meditation say by Tara brach or Sam
Harris and that is for state awareness
then I sit down with a cup of tea very
often puer plus turmeric and ginger and
I use a journal most often that is a
five minute journal and this is to
clarify my in my intense objectives and
also gratitude for the day which
decreases anxiety I find that to be an
important precursor for me personally
for optimal output and that is really it
literally that takes about 30 40 minutes
and if that means this is very hard for
me to bite off and accept because I am a
night owl and love sleeping late if I
need to sleep
30 minutes less to get that boot-up
sequence completed that is a worthwhile
investment and I will very often people
to make that up later with a 30-minute
let's just say caffeine nap later in the
day you can Google caffeine nap if you
want know what that is so am i
completely psychotic and obsessive and
so on probably but not because of my
interest in morning routines almost
every guest on this podcast has an
interesting approach to the beginning of
the day whether that is highly highly
structured or completely unstructured
there's usually some thought behind it
their habits and practices can help set
the stage for you so without further ado
let's get started
Jaco willing spent 20 years in the u.s.
Navy and commanded SEAL Teams three task
unit bruiser the most highly decorated
special operations unit in the Iraq war
upon returning to the u.s. jaco served
as the officer in charge of training for
all West Coast SEAL Teams designing and
implementing some of the most
challenging and realistic perhaps
psychotic combat training in the world
after retiring from the Navy he
co-founded a leadership and management
consulting company and authored the
number one New York Times bestseller
extreme ownership how US Navy SEALs lead
and win he did his first ever interview
on this podcast he also hosts a
fantastic podcast called jaco podcast
which you should check out it's intense
now in our conversation I started by
asking Jocko at least in this excerpt
what his morning routines look like and
how he would structure his ideal day
here's what he said so I wake up early I
wake up at 4:45 I like to have that
psychological win over the enemy and you
know for me that when I wake up in the
morning and I don't know why I'm
thinking about the enemy and what
they're doing and I know I'm not active
duty anymore but it's still in there
that there's a guy that's in a cave
somewhere and he's rocking back and
forth and he's got a machine gun in one
hand and a grenade in the other hand and
he's waiting for me and we're gonna meet
and when I wake up in the morning I'm
thinking to myself what can I do to be
ready for that moment which is coming
which is coming and so that that propels
me out of bed that and I work out early
in the morning you wake up at 4:45
what's the next thing aside from like
brushing it then doing the usual do the
usual start working out and I try
ideally I like to get done with my
workout by the time the Sun comes up and
so now if there's waves you know I live
by the ocean so I'll go surfing and get
done with that and what is the morning
workout what does a typical morning
workout look like I I you know I do a
lot of pull-ups push-ups and dips I
deadlift and do squats I do sprints I
mean it's everything that everybody
knows it's everything that everybody
does right I swing kettlebells do
burpees you know it's it's all that and
it's like a 60 minute workout how long
is it depends it depends on what's going
on I will
I'll try and do some strength movements
to be strong you know deadlifts cleans
clean-and-jerk something like that to
make myself stronger or even if it's
even if it's something like just dead
hang pull ups and I'm just maxing out
but I I'll do something like that to
make myself stronger and sometimes that
can take a while
you know because I'll just want to relax
and and you know hit singles or doubles
on deadlifts or cleans or whatever and
then when I get done with that I'll do
some kind of some kind of metabolic
conditioning of some kind you know I'll
be sprinting or rowing or swimming in a
kettle bell or you know lighter weight
clean and jerks for reps or something
like that so that's what it looks like
for me
so you finish training when the Sun
comes up hit the waves since they're
there which is a good policy and what
happens then you know I'll come back and
you know start doing normal human stuff
right that's when the work I have
leadership and management consulting
business so I'll have clients to talk to
all of emails to push out and you know
I'll start taking care of that business
I normally don't get hungry until 10 or
11 o'clock in the morning so around 10
or 11 o'clock I start wanting you know
to start to graze on some food and I'll
do that and and then by by noon I'm
feeling pretty hungry like I need some
lunch and what is what is your diet
generally look like generally looks like
steak steak and chicken and salad paleo
fish yeah yeah and I don't know you know
I'm no stranger to having some mint
chocolate chip ice cream or some
Ovaltine or whatever you know again I'm
not I'm not you know a competitive
bodybuilder
and so you know I I'll eat some normal
food right you can indulge when they
when the spirit moves you when you think
of the word successful who were the
first people where the first person that
comes to mind
so for me you know the part of the world
that I've seen is a very dark place it's
a dark place
that's what war is and when your job
which my job was was to expand that
darkness in many ways I mean it's the
war is about killing people and so for
me when I look to someone that's
successful it's someone that brings some
light into that darkness so for me the
first people that come to my head are
mark Lee who is one of my guys first CEO
killed in Iraq Mike Mansoor one of my
guys second seal killed in Iraq
posthumously awarded the Medal of Honor
and Ryan job one of my guys wounded in
Iraq blinded in both eyes made it home
medically retired from the from the Navy
married his high school sweetheart
daughter pregnant and finished his
college degree and after his 22nd
surgery to repair the damage that was
done to his his head and face there were
complications and he died as well but
all of those guys in all that darkness
they did
things they made a sacrifice that was
completely selfless and to do that and
to live and fight and die like a warrior
that to me is success and those guys are
my heroes what do you what do you
struggle with and I asked that because I
mean we've we've only just met but it's
hard for me as a civilian to fathom what
what you and your friends have been
through impossible for me to found them
and I mean it makes me just feel ashamed
for ever complaining about a bad day or
a hard day given what you guys have
experienced in the stakes that are
involved and the sacrifices and the
sadness and tragedy that is a part of
that job what do you struggle with
whether it's in the business sphere or
just in life in general if you're open
to talking about it cuz I certainly I
know that I used to know when I had
these icons in my head I was like oh my
god Richard Branson he's got it all
figured out he's doing everything
perfectly he's just he's on cruise
control hitting home runs every time it
gets it bad
and as I've slowly gotten to know
non-soy Branson directly although I have
met him before I realize like people all
have and this is something that you
talked about that detachment you know
when I find myself I've always had kind
of impatience and anger issues
and it's helped me to be aggressive in
sport and in business and in negotiation
but it's also caused some problems for
me and but I've realized that one of the
ways I can tone that down is my
realizing like everybody had everyone is
fighting a battle you know nothing about
in some way but what what are the things
that that you find difficult or that you
struggle with or have struggled with
it's it's it's an interesting question
because and this is a filler answer in
case you couldn't tell that because when
I start off with it's an interesting
question that means I'm not really quite
sure what to say I've you know I've been
I've been lucky I've been blessed I've
had you know a life that I would not
trade with anyone in the world when you
talk about Ramadi I that was the
highlight of my life because I was
leading men in combat which is something
which was something that I always wanted
to do and something that I felt that I
was destined to do and when I was in
that situation I knew that I wasn't I
don't look back and say oh I wish I
would have enjoyed that know I knew it
then this is it this is this is what you
have been waiting for your whole life
and what you really have been preparing
for your whole life and I was lucky to
be there and I was lucky to have
incredible guys to work with both in my
unit and in the other units the Army and
the Marine Corps that we worked with I
was lucky enough to have guys that were
so brave and so dedicated and I will I
will use the word fearless not that they
didn't have fear but that they overcame
it all the time and so I'd say if
there's anything that I struggle with
now it's just that does anything else
matter is there in the answer's no the
answer is no nothing else matters
nothing else is close and so you
have to deal with that and and I don't
struggle is a strong word because I
don't sit there at night you know
wishing I was back well okay I do do
that you know
sometimes that I often wish I was back
but I don't dwell on it because it's
gone and I'm so happy that I could be
part of it
and that I was able to work with such
tremendous guys and I try and keep their
memory live everyday in my own head next
up is Seth Godin I love Seth he is one
of the most influential marketers in the
world and his blog which nearly anyone
at the top of the marketing world has
read at some point is followed by the
who's who of people in the persuasion
and influence game whether that is in
marketing advertising or otherwise he
has authored 18 maybe more best-selling
books that have been translated into 35
plus languages around the world
he was founded several companies and
most of all if you look at all of his
various projects he challenges the
status quo in all areas he loves testing
assumptions which makes me love you Seth
it's true hope you're listening thanks
Seth
his books include linchpin tribes the
dip Purple Cow and what to do when it's
your turn and then in parentheses and
it's always your turn in this short clip
Seth talks about self-discipline the
busy trap and gives some best practices
anyone can use whether you're a parent
or a so-called watch or printer
on the subject of eating what do your
eating habits look like what does your
diet look like yeah it's really not good
it's not good well it's not good because
I'm bored by it but people are
fascinated when we go out to dinner
because there's so I don't eat wheat I
don't eat dairy
I don't need cilantro I don't eat meat
because each time I sort of adjust what
I eat I feel better and so I feel like I
am in a happy place where I can make
fascinating interesting food and mostly
eat happily in restaurants without being
obsessive about it
what is the first say two hours of your
day look like and what is breck what is
your what is a typical breakfast
breakfast is one more decision I don't
make so it's a frozen banana hemp powder
almond milk a dried plum and some
walnuts in the blender and then I make
coffee for whoever comes over that
morning and for my lovely wife and
meanwhile I've probably done an hour and
a half of stuff online before 7:30 so
then I know the world didn't break when
I was asleep and then I can get to work
what is the half hour of triage Internet
triage or computer triage to look like
what do what types of things are you
doing in that half hour well the most
important thing is did the blog work
because if it didn't I have to take a
vase of action but I love the guys at
TypePad it's the best 29 bucks a month I
spend because it doesn't crash and it
works and then I try to clear the email
box
I've lived in inbox zero since before it
was coined and now my brain is free and
so then I try not to be an email hound
until I've done actual productive work
and then I come to the apartment where I
work and other people join me here
sometimes and
work on the old MBA which is the school
I am building and that's what I do for
work so and when was the last time you
worked at home if you ever did well if
there's a laptop or I'm not unconscious
I'm at work in the sense that what I do
for a living is notice things right
right I guess the the reason I ask is
I'm I've long considered getting an
office as opposed to operating out of
coffee shops and miscellaneous locations
and that is the the context behind the
question yeah it's I do much better in
this room this room is I couldn't
recreate this room for ten million
dollars it's got so much fátima
it's got patina on the patina and that
sets a bar for me about the fact that I
don't want to compromise just to do the
next thing because I look at the last
thing or the thing before that and I say
damn I'm proud of that don't do
something you're not proud of so you
know the all ten be a I wouldn't be
running it still if it wasn't the single
most important educational thing I've
ever done and that's what I keep trying
to do is the next thing's got to be
worthy of it or else I might as well
just take a break
could you elaborate because a lot of the
questions from my fans on Twitter and
Facebook were related to education and
they they generally came in the form of
in a number of themes one was you know
could you have him lab write on his
education manifesto and the other was
hey I have a kid who's in fourth grade I
have a kid who's just going to be
entering school what would Seth do in my
shoes and you don't have to tackle those
right off the bat but as that is context
could you could you tell us more about
what you're up to
alright so this is a rant and is not
about what I'm up to it's about what I
was up to and the rant is this sooner or
later parents have to take
responsibility for putting their kids
into a system that is indebting them and
teaching them to be cogs in a
economy that doesn't want cogs anymore
and parents get to decide I'm abuse fan
of public school send my kids to public
school I think everyone should go to
public school cuz it's a great mix
master of our world but from three
o'clock to ten o'clock those kids are
getting homeschooled
and they're either getting home schooled
and watching The Flintstones or they get
in home schooled in learning something
useful and I think we need to teach kids
two things one how to lead and two how
to solve interesting problems because
the fact is there are plenty of
countries on earth where there are
people who are willing to be obedient
and work harder for less money than us
so we cannot out obedience the
competition therefore we have to out
lead or out solve the other people I
don't care what country they live in in
Wyoming or across the world who want
that whatever is scarce the way you
teach your kids to solve interesting
problems is to give them interesting
problems to solve and then don't
criticize them when they fail because
kids aren't stupid if they get in
trouble every time they try to solve an
interesting problem they'll just go back
to getting an A by memorizing what's in
the textbook that it's so important here
and I spend an enormous amount of time
with kids I produced the The Wizard of
Oz the musical in fourth grade I used to
help run a summer camp I think that it's
a privilege to be able to look at
rusting energetic smart eleven-year-old
in the eye and tell them the truth and
what we can say to that 11 year old is I
really don't care how you did on your
vocabulary test I care about whether you
have something to say and we can teach
our kids from a young age to be the kind
of people we want them to be and
anything that's worth memorizing is
worth looking up now so we don't need to
have them spend a lot of time getting
good grade so they can go into a famous
college because
as college just don't work anymore
famous college isn't the point anymore
the point is is there an entity that
will have trouble living without you
when you seek turn eleven because if
there is you'll be able to make a living
if on the other hand you're waiting in
the placement office for someone to pick
you you will be persistently undervalued
you talked earlier about writing daily
as a practice listening to the audio
books as a practice are there any
practices that you would suggest to the
kind of overwhelmed busy parent who
wants to start to be more proactive in
this department they have an 11 year old
are there any practices or exercises
that they that you would suggest well
you know super well that busy is a trap
and that business is a myth so what
could possibly be more important than
your kid please don't play the busy card
if you spend two hours a day without an
electronic device looking your kid in
the eye talking to them and solving
interesting problems you will raise a
different kid than someone who doesn't
do that and that's one of the reasons
why I cook dinner every night because
what a wonderful semi distracted
environment for the kid to tell you the
truth for you to have low stakes but
super important conversations with
someone who's important to you right
that this idea get home from work
put on your sneakers and go for a walk
with your kid you know my friend Brian
walks his daughter to school every day
that's priceless well how can you be too
busy to do that and the work you're
doing now so I did a couple courses for
Skillshare they worked really well they
were very highly rated and they had a 80
percent dropout rate which is way better
than anybody else because other online
courses have a 97% dropout rate then I
did of course for you to me and the same
thing happened and I'm thinking I love
making these courses and you know there
I am on screen it sounds like me but why
are people dropping
of my courses and everyone else's and
the reason is because when it gets hard
and there's no social pressure you leave
so what I said was how do I make the
opposite of an online course and that
meant instead of a million people a
hundred it meant instead of being free
it's expensive instead of letting
everyone in you have to apply instead of
being easy it's hard and instead of
being on your own it's a group thing
where there are coaches watching you all
the time and instead of lectures it's
100 percent projects so I built it to
see what would happen and so the all 10
BA is for people and big companies we've
got people from Whole Foods and
Microsoft and it's for people that tiny
companies and it's not for everybody but
we get this cohort of people and there's
a coach for every 10 we put them in
slack
we put them in WordPress we give them 14
assignments over a 28-day period of time
and we sprint as fast as we can and it's
unbelievable Tim I just gotta tell you
it's unbelievable cuz I'm not actively
involved I just watch and because
eventually the goal is to have more of
these sessions I can't be in them if
they have more of them and people change
because we don't give them any other
choice could you could you expand on the
social pressure piece I think this is
such an important point and I was asked
recently I get asked all the time maybe
you get asked this too but like how do
you maintain the discipline or how do
you change this habit how do you do this
and my answer is almost always they
sound like you have to have a punishment
or a reward for following or not
following it for doing it or not doing
it and it's it's it's just incredible to
see how people who've never been able to
lose weight before as soon as they have
a hundred dollars of their own money on
the line and it's a betting pool with
five other people who will be able to
heckle them at the office all of a
sudden they figure it out really quickly
and the how-to isn't as hard but in in
in this particular example can you
expand on the the social aspect because
I think it's really really important and
transfers and it applies to a lot of
other areas
there are some people in some areas who
have the self-discipline necessary to
get the work done that needs to get done
you know those people and I need and I
know those people and when we find one
of them it's fabulous like I think I am
like that with certain parts of my craft
in that no one would notice if I didn't
do it the way I do it I just choose to
do it when it comes to education though
all of us have 12 to 20 years of
brainwashing going on with which is
epitomized by one sentence
I hate with a passion which is will this
be on the test right so as soon as you
say will this be on the test
you've instantly defined why you are
doing something and then when we invite
you to an online course for free on
artificial intelligence in which there
is no certificate which there's no
accreditation and you get to problem
number four and it's really hard and you
ask yourself will this be on the test
and then you realize there is no test
and no one even knows you're taking the
course then you stop and you go eat some
M&Ms and you turn on the TV and so the
goal here was if you need if you benefit
if you thrive from being in an
environment where you will push yourself
to get what you wanted all along
I'll give you people who will push you
your fellow students and your coaches
and there won't be a test and there
won't be grades this is better than that
this is teaching you to you know
internalize the narrative of my mom's
not here my mom's not watching but I
should act like she was
I spent two and a half hours with Jamie
Fox in his home recording studio Jamie
for those who don't know is an Academy
Award winning actor Grammy award-winning
musician and of course he cut his teeth
as a stand-up and improv comedian he can
do it all he's the most consummate
performer and entertainer I've ever met
he's really phenomenal in this
particular episode and you can hear the
whole thing at tim dot blog /j me this
episode ended up winning podcast of the
year the year came out and has voted on
product hunt his morning routine plays
an important role in the structure of
his day let him tell you all about it
what is what is the first 60 minutes of
your day look like or what give any
morning routines that are important to
you morning routines I wake up I I text
the people that I didn't love what you
say I just send them encouraging like
you know there's a few you know people
that just you know really mean a lot to
me
wanna let them know I'm thinking about
them hold on and then uh it varies man
sometimes I'd be like okay I put some
work in so I put in eight days so maybe
these two days I could share get a
little I do the just on the physical
part I get my own I get my 50 pull-ups a
hundred situps
you know maybe a hundred of every one
hundred crunches and it's easy I used to
not be able to do it my boy tyrant how
many sets for the fifty pull for the
fifty started do 15 first 15 pull-ups
this is what it is I do 15 pull-ups 50
pushups 100 sit-ups then I go back and I
do 15 different
I'll check rip yeah so that'll get me to
30 another 50 pushups thank you spend
one hundred push-ups I'm done with the
push-ups and then I do ten and ten back
to the to the first grip and you don't
have to do it every single day you can
do it every other day and then what you
notice is the pull-up bar
and tiring kept telling me this well we
got a home retirement he played cane and
Minister society and he I kept wondering
how is he always in shape he says man
I'm trying to tell you the pull-up bar
is everything so uh so that and then uh
and then just you don't make the calls
and what I need to get done and make
sure I'm you know on the right you know
position and you drink coffee the kid I
don't drink coffee I don't drink coffee
is have you stopped I had to stop having
stimulants earlier in my career I was I
was all about the stimulant
ixnay on that I've been I've been
cutting that out as well it's not good
for me people are like aren't you
worried about depressants alcohol like
no no no stimulants that's what I needs
because when I tell people time to drink
coffee after a while you you keep you
keep hitting that same muscle you know
and your brain to where you I know
people right now who could drink four
cups of coffee and go to sleep
yeah I used to be that first yeah and so
it's like my and one of our boys loves
uh what is the Red Bull red ball and
then he won't understand how some days
he'll just be like this yeah so I had to
stop and it was tough because I had to
have coffee every day and not drink like
double espressos you know I was like I
had to have the up yeah but now I know
how to go get it inside of my you know I
know how to go get it inside last last
question here is I'm gonna ask what
advice you would give to yourself three
different ages twenty thirty and forty
so what advice would you give to your 20
year old self man put the condom on
[Music]
important advice anything else for 20 or
should we move to thirty twenty twenties
I had my daughter 26 so the advice I
would give me was like calm down you
know it was like calm down and
and just you know make sure you're
paying attention to your daughter answer
the daughter's mom 20s was tough cuz I
just got the LA I was just you know man
the whole world was opening up so I'm
like man I'm you know I'm trying to do
all of it and while I was like calm down
and and luckily it was 26 so moving into
30 I was on my way to calming if that
makes it does make sense so then you
have 30 turning what advice would you
give your 30 year old self but it's
gotta go fast in what way it's gotta go
fast the time is gonna go fast so just
make sure that you uh you start now
planning for your future and not only is
gonna go fast but don't spend all your
money don't buy the the jacket that's
twelve thousand dollars you know relax
you know just just you relax it because
it's good and if forty is gonna come so
fast and you don't think that it is but
it's gonna come so fast and would you
say that because you would want your
thirty year old self to pay attention to
the present moment or do long-term
thinking turn when you're thirty you got
a kid and you're in my business and in
any business all businesses are gonna
especially when you when you when you
make my businesses about me know so I
have to be careful in my decisions
socially and plan for the future it's
not gonna be I remember uh doing my
television show and it went five years
went fast and I would tell the people on
my television show it's gonna go fast
man and if you finish it thirty five but
you live till 70 you know so you have to
really think about the future the long
game yeah and then forty before zero Wow
forty there they're gonna be tough
decisions that you have to make when it
comes to business cuz in your forty when
you're forty in my business the window
is closing
certain things so you have to be able to
open those windows to other things and
some of the people that you've gone to
battle with till you're 40 may not be
the ones that you will battle and do
business with towards 50 and take a
little bit of your personal feelings out
of it because I'm very personal meaning
like I would stay with someone even if I
feel that they're not up to par
business-wise but you know we have
history take a little bit of the
personal out of it still remain friends
if you care about that person because
now it's really pending like 50 bout to
be here you know saying so it's like you
know and I would tell my for to yourself
grow up in your mind but not in your
body necessarily mmm
meaning stay young in your body but
certain parts of your life
you have to grow up and be be grown
about things because now you got another
kid your other child is you know 21
she's 21 now which is just you know his
past year so but she was you know 13 14
and if when I was 40 but now you got to
start living you would always live your
life 100% for you but now that you have
your kids in there a certain age it's
got to be 30 to 40 percent you 60 to 7%
what you're gonna leave for them and how
you gonna leave them because it's like I
said it's it's flying and that's it
Jamie so much fun I really appreciate
taking the time and where can people
find what you're up to find you online
learning yeah I am Jamie Fox on my
periscope am i right am I saying is
right you know I got these young cats
chilling with and then I'm Jamie Fox on
Twitter also Jamie Fox at Twitter I'm
doing better on Twitter I'm trying to do
better and and the old fella John the
latest album the latest albums called
Hollywood story of a dozen roses just
out I don't care how you get it you can
download it bootleg it steal it from a
friend I don't care I just want you to I
just want you to hear the music the song
is out right now
I'm supposed to be in love by now I'm
supposed to be in love but now it's been
so long for me I don't know how I've
been drowning in the sea of broken vows
but I'm supposed to be in love while now
[Music]
I've been chasing my dream now I'm
chasing you
running hard but my legs feel weak
I don't played every part I don't play
the fool right the movie of Bo Lee I'm
supposed to be in love below
oh girl you stole my heart take in love
by now so make sure you get that and
love by now is out it's a song that my
daughter made me she sort of made me do
she's like listen stop with the club
stuff stop with it that's my oldest
daughters I thought he said start with
the club joints stop you're trying to be
too young like even she's even like I
had on some shoes one day that she
thought was just I had too young of a
shoe she's like dad what is that on your
feet I said wish you did a new style
baby
did you set his you know new style I had
a zipper on a buckle and my name and
grade and she was like stop it she said
dad you have old feet
I said wasn't me you have old fit like
you have your feet for marching like the
civil-rights right so but she said do a
song that we know that is from you in
history that I'm supposed being loved by
now and so uh so that and jumping out of
the window and we just shot the in love
by now video with George Lopez is the
priest I get stood up at the altar
George Lopez is a priest Nicole
Scherzinger and we all know her from the
Pussycat Doll but also her solo career
and everything she plays my love
interest which is great because she's a
good friend so we were able to like
really get into some like you know they
don't do old school videos anymore like
this actually has a bit of a story but
man tank is in it and then all of my
friends my daughter is in it my little
daughter is in it and my mom and dad is
in it you know so it's kind of cool
Scott Adams is the creator of Dilbert
which has been published in more than
2,000 newspapers in 57 countries and in
19 languages in this next segment Scott
talks about his six dimensions of humor
but I started by asking Scott about the
structure of his morning
beginning with the exact time that he
wakes up so depending on when I went to
sleep either five or six but let's say
five I get up and I walk directly
downstairs and get my coffee so push one
button and wait for it
have my one protein bar which is always
the same because if the coffee is always
the same the proteins are always the
same and the time is always the same
give or take that hour because I'm
removing decisions what type of protein
bar do you eat I eat a builder's 20 gram
protein bar chocolate peanut butter and
I'm so smart that I actually picked it
up and they had the label in front of me
because I expected that question oh you
know me well at that point I usually get
on and start looking I guess I checked
you know Twitter first check my web page
to see if when they playing blew up that
I don't know about no did I did I say
anything yesterday that causes the world
to melt down because you know I'll need
to know about that failing that I
usually open Business Insider
because I just like reading it or
they're usually while I'm waiting for my
coffee I've looked at my facebook feed
and you know just tweeted you know
played around basically I'm just trying
to wake up get my mind working and
there's a process where once you clear
your mind you have to flaunt it and you
may use different words for this but I
know you do it
so you empty it and then you flood it
with new input that's not the old input
so I'm looking at the news I'm looking
at stuff I haven't seen I'm not looking
at yesterday's problem for the fifth
time I'm looking at a new problem I'm
thinking of a new idea so flooding and
all the all the the new stuff but any
then you gotta find out where in there
flood is
a little piece that's worth working with
and that's where I that's where I use
the body model I kind of cycle through
all this this dotty model you said yeah
so the model is your brain can't find
good content right not directly in an
intellectual sense obviously the brain
is involved but what I mean is that as
I'm thinking of these ideas and they're
flowing through the my head I'm
monitoring my body
I'm not monitoring in my mind and when
my body changes I have something that
other people are gonna care about - oh
that's cool I like that so yeah that
means posture or what what type of
indicators are there I'll tell you when
if I'm thinking of let's say a
particular setup for a joke I'll think
of the joke and then quite often I'll go
right and it wasn't playing right it
just it's just what it was sort of a
half laugh that you do when you're by
yourself and you say think of something
funny but you don't want to do a full
laugh you know so there's sort of thing
there are other times when so for
example I told you the story about being
in the shower and thinking is the entire
plot for God's debris in one moment you
know my entire body lit up when I had
the idea for the blog that I wrote
recently they just sort of lit up the
internet I felt it as a full-body
experience long before I wrote it right
and so that's that's largely true now
with Dilbert if you do this long enough
a lot of the things that used to be
technique just get baked into your
personality after a while and so there's
stuff you do as second nature that
you're kind of moving art into the
domain of craft right so for example I
know because I've you know learned over
time that there are six elements of
dimension of humor six dimensions of
humor and if I use at least two of them
I've got a joke if I use three of them
it's probably gonna be a really good
joke but that's not enough there's still
that there's something about it that X
Factor that thing you can't put your
foot your finger on that just makes your
body move you know it just moves your
body and if you can't get that no craft
in the world can survive you know we
can't resuscitate it and have you have
you you've written about
the the six elements of humor before I
did I written about a number of times I
think if anybody googles my name Scott
Adams and six dimensions of humor you'll
see oh yeah you'll see a few references
to it and what would be two examples of
the six just just for fun oh I know
you're good at this because you know
what you just did that was just so smart
if you would it if you ask me for the
six I would have changed the subject but
you asked me for - because you know I
could come up with - all right so I'm
gonna go for six because you've now made
it you've made it safe for me to do so
there's cute there's bizarre
there's recognizable there's naughty
nobody was that yeah you're already way
ahead of the game you got four you got
cute bizarre recognizable and naughty
yeah you have to Google the rest a
little bit let me give you an example
so cute is usually kids and dogs right
so and bizarre is just anything that's
out of place so if you know your cartoon
history you will know that the far side
use primarily the dimension of putting
something out of place so you'd have an
animal talking so as soon as the animals
talking he's got one dimension all right
so he's basically starting a race and
he's already ahead of you if you're the
cartoonist who's sitting there saying I
think they'll do a comic about anything
the world is my canvas right but he
start you started to and even already so
he's got the bizarre and then he'll have
the animal say something often in the
framing or the type of mood that a human
would say right so that's a recognizable
part so if you could put yourself in the
picture and say aha god I recognize that
situation but it's an animal talking
clearly there's more to it than that
again that's just that you have to have
at least that two dimensions take a look
at the best comic strip of all time that
I think nearly everyone in the world
would say Calvin and Hobbes there's a
there's a talking tiger that is both
bizarre and cute
all right so he took the far side one
dimension further as a starting point
all right the moment you start reading
Calvin and Hobbes you already have cute
because his drawing is amazing both of
the the child and the you know he's got
a double cute he's got a child and an
animal and it's a cool animal right so
he starts that before he even writes a
joke so then if he has the kid doing
something you know naughty or also
anything bad happening to anybody is of
course one of the dimensions so cruelty
did I mention cruelty am i up to five
yet you're up to five that's number five
shoot by the end of this interview I
will have come up with that six one and
I'm gonna I'm gonna scream it in the
middle of whatever other unrelated
question could you perhaps explain a bit
of how you use affirmations if you do
you have accidentally given me the
greatest beginning anecdote to a long
explanation anybody ever did so right
true story just a few days ago I was
having dinner with navall and I'm just
making conversation you know we haven't
seen him in a while and just randomly
because I knew I was coming on your
podcast I said if all if you ever done
the you know Tim Ferriss podcast and he
gets his weird expression in his face
and he says I just came from there it
was the most random thing any two people
who could have said to each other after
not seeing for a while but that that
weird story is a story about coincidence
right yeah there's no magic to happen
there it was just a strange coincidence
and probably wasn't even the coincidence
because the fact that we both know you
and you know there's something in the
air and maybe you bunch your bunch your
interviews in a certain way or think
about it in a certain way so I'm sure
there's no real coincidence there
there's just some we didn't see
underlying it all so that's the backdrop
for affirmations let me say first that
what I'm saying is not my belief that if
you say your affirmations something
magical will happen and the universe
will change and in some non science way
all right so I never made that claim
although often people have put that
opinion in my mouth
what I have said is that I've used the
technique and I got a certain experience
which I'll be happy to share and that I
tell the story alright you can make of
it what you will
I have several explanations for why
there seems to be what I would call the
the appearance of an effect which by the
way would be amazing in itself of course
you could give yourself a genuine
feeling that you had a superpower even
if it wasn't real as long as it didn't
you know interfere with your job nobody
thought you were crazy it'd be a cool
feeling so so even if it's not real and
some sense of reality still worth having
frankly so we'd have I'm gonna take as
long as I want for this and you can just
cut me off it's a fun story from
beginning to end I like a lot of people
ask this is what this is what this
format is for long format please go for
it yeah alright so I'm in my 20s I was
taking a course in the hypnosis to learn
how to become a professional hypnotist
and get certified in my class was a
woman who was also interested in a lot
of things that I thought were pretty out
there some new agey stuff but we became
friends and one day she said you gotta
try this thing called affirmations I
read about it in a book and I don't
remember the name of the book and so I
can't tell you here cuz she couldn't
tell me and she said it works like this
all you do is you you pick a goal and
your write it down 15 times a day and
some specific sentence form like I Scott
Adams will become an astronaut for
example and you do that every day and
then it will seem as if the universe
just starts spitting up opportunities
and it will look to you like these are
coincidences and whether there or not is
less relevant than the fact that they
seem to pop up so I of course being my
rational self you know at this point I
haven't even decided if hypnosis is a
real thing right right yeah I'm taking
the course to find out in part and so
I'm saying you know that seems like a
terrible waste of time there's no
science behind that blah blah blah she
convinced me partly because she was a
member of Mensa there she wasn't dumb
and step that's good and then secondly
it didn't cost me anything right it was
a low investment for something to bake
her shut up so I said I I'm gonna do
this thing so I picked as my goal that I
would have an encounter with a woman who
was well beyond my buying power shall we
say this is pre Dilbert so you know post
post Dilbert you get to add a few points
to your attractiveness scale it's not
fair but that's just the way it works so
let's say if you know if I could
honestly say I was a six hoping to be a
six and a half yeah let's say she was a
nine just to get a sense of the
monumental task i sat in front of myself
secondly I didn't know her she was just
somebody who worked in the company in a
different department so I'll shorten his
story just to say lucky things happened
and against all odds my affirmation came
true so I thought to myself as everybody
would in this situation well it's not
really the affirmation that worked that
would be crazy right because even though
it was a whole bunch of ridiculous
coincidences that put us in the same
place you know at the same time I mean
you wouldn't believe the number of them
and I won't tell them here because
they're they're just too many but in the
end it was almost like we were fated to
meet all right I don't believe in that
but it just felt like that that's the
experience so I said to myself well I
guess I've misinterpreted this and
really what happened is I'm not as six
and a half dammit I must be horrible or
maybe maybe I'm a seven and a half and
maybe she's a nine but she's got be a
poor self-image so she didn't know it so
maybe that's all that happened right so
I said well I'm gonna have to try
something else so I said all right I'll
try affirmation of I'll get rich in the
stock market now that's kind of a crazy
thing to ask for especially if you don't
even have a stock brokerage account open
and if you don't have any money to
invest I think I was you know the poor
banking person a banker that was and so
I started doing that information and
after about a week I literally woke up
in the middle of the night sat straight
up in my bed with a thought firmly in my
head that I should buy stock in Chrysler
that time I don't remember the year but
if you know if you went through the
historical records it was when Chrysler
was flirting with completely going out
of business who was I don't know if they
were officially bankrupt but they were
they were the government had pumped them
up and most observers were saying you
know this is sort of the the company
that's circling the drain so it didn't
seem like a good idea and but I tried to
open my Schwab account anyway and pursue
it just to see you know we're still in a
be testing here to see if this is real
but the paperwork got mixed up and it
took weeks to sort it out and I didn't
get my account opened in the meantime
the stock starts rising you know I think
it went up 220 percent in the time that
I wasted trying to open my account so I
thought to myself damn I was kinda right
you know I mean I picked a pretty good
stock but you know my timings off so I
guess the affirmation thing wasn't
really working so I didn't buy that
stock if you if you go back you'll find
out it continued to go up because it
turns out Chrysler did it turned around
it was one of the great business success
stories of all time I knew nothing about
that except you know the headline news
before I came up with this idea in other
words there's no story I read no analyst
was ahead of it it just came from
nowhere or so as or so it seemed well I
I lost out because I didn't trust it i
guess right i didn't buy and it became
kind of the story stock of the year
right so i tried it one more time i said
i think i'll try to you know buy one
more stock and i did the affirmation one
day i pick up the newspaper and i just
had this feeling and I open it up and
there's a back in the day when a company
was going public they would sometimes
put a a big notice in the newspaper it
was a company called ask computer ASX or
ask software I forget but there were a
new tech company back before tech was
anything and I said hey I'm gonna invest
in this company I just feel put in some
money I think it went up 10% in a week
whatever it was I thought I'm a genius I
think I've invested about a thousand
dollars mighta made a hundred which was
big money for a week of doing nothing
you know when you're when you're not
making enough money to save money making
$100 for nothing seem like a big deal so
I'm thinking man I am so smart sold my
stock and that fricking stock went to
the moon
and now I've got these three these three
data points right and the only thing
that stopped me from the two doing very
well for me is that I didn't stay with
them so I said well it would be dumb if
this thing actually has something to it
to send another goal that's relatively
modest right so so there was another
thing I'd yet first let me insert that
before I went back I also made it bet
with somebody that I would take the the
G maths the test you take to get it into
a good school for your MBA because I'd
taken them right after I'd finished my
four-year degree and I've got I think
the 77th percentile which is nowhere
near enough to get into a school like
Berkeley which which would make a
difference in my career so I made a bet
with somebody who's going to take a prep
course they were gonna try to raise
their score in two from the 80s and
something perhaps the the 90s in order
to get into a good school
again like Berkeley so I made a bet and
I don't know why I made this bet it was
just stupid in retrospect I bet that I
would raise my score from 77th
percentile to whatever was her new best
score so I would beat not only her other
score which already beat me by over ten
points I think or maybe you know she was
in the high 80s I think but I thought I
would beat her new score and I wasn't
gonna take a test preparation course I
was just gonna take some you know
practice tests on my own at home so I
did that but I paired it with the
affirmation and then I also visualized
which is part of the process they tell
you to do very specifically what my
score would look like on the exact
document I knew I would get because I
had taken this test before years earlier
and so I would imagine that in that
little box where the the cumulative
score was I would see the the number 94
and so I just kept you know focusing on
94 cuz I figured that would be close
enough that if I got anywhere in that
range you know then I'm probably going
to get into a good school if I want to
so we take the test I my every one of my
practice tests I got about the same as
the first time I took it somewhere in
the high 70s percentile I take the test
felt exactly the same as all the
practice tests I didn't feel like I was
having a good day or anything weeks
passed
shows up in the mail go to the mailbox I
opened the mail they opened that letter
and it's the same same kind of format
that I visualized so I knew exactly what
it looked like and looked out into the
little box where for weeks I had been
visualizing the number 94 and I looked
at it and the [ __ ] thing said 94 all
right this was after the stock market
experience yeah getting my timing mixed
up it was saying they're roughly in that
period right so I literally sat there in
my little mold covered literally
apartment in San Francisco in the Haight
district I sat in a chair and I stared
forward for hours and all night long I
would I would say to myself I don't
think I just saw that and then I would
reach over on my table and pick up the
little report and I would look at it
again and I would make sure I was
scouring the document and not reading
like a date or a you know a serial
number or something right and it was
writing I'd put it down and then I would
just repeat that process for hours and
that the other day I said I think I'm
gonna set my sights higher and it wasn't
long after I decided to start the
affirmation my scott adams would become
a famous cartoonist so i he was there
were some years that passed in between
and then some other affirmations but
that's that's essentially the the path I
took
well there you have folks this is the
Tim Ferriss Radio Hour and I hope you
enjoyed hearing from some of the
superstars I've spoken with over nearly
250 podcasts now oh my god no wonder
that les harán I think Tim Ferriss Brady
our continues to be an experiment this
format is experimental so please let me
know what you like what you don't like
what you would want to hear any themes
any changes let me know on is it with us
on Twitter you can pay me at tea Farris
TFE our our ISS or you can leave a
comment on the blog post which will
accompany this episode which has all the
show notes any links to anything that is
mentioned in this episode you can find
that at Tim blog forward slash podcast
which is where you can find all previous
episodes of the podcast and if you want
to hear from some of the people who
popped up in this episode well the Jaime
episode a must listen Tim top blog /gm
e20 here Seth go to Tim da blog forward
slash Seth if you want to hear from
Scott Adams you can go to Tim blog
forward slash Scott and then Jaco of
course yo you can get tuned up blog
forward slash Jocko and as always guys
thank you so so much
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me would
you enjoy getting a short email for me
every Friday that provides a little
morsel of fun before the weekend and
five bullet Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out
just go to 4-hour workweek dot-com
that's four hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you will get the very next one
and if you sign up I hope you enjoyed
this episode is brought to you by
99designs I've used 99designs for ages
since even before podcasting was the
thing and I've used them for all sorts
of graphic design needs they are fast
and they are convenient whether you need
a logo website book cover or anything
else I've done competitions for instance
for covers related to the 4-hour body
99designs makes great design accessible
to everyone and it makes the process so
much easier and I use them recently for
artwork and illustrations inside of my
cow of Seneca set of books so this is a
collection of stoic writing and modern
interviews and so on so for the Tao of
Seneca I decided to use their one-to-one
project service in this case you invite
a specific designer to your project
agree on a price and then work together
until you're satisfied and the artwork
just blew my mind
you have to check it out I kid you not
so you can check out some of the artwork
from Toph Seneca as well as some artwork
and logos and so on that your fellow
listeners have had made at 99 designs
dot-com forward-slash Tim that's
99designs com forward slash Tim I really
suggest you check it out
and right now you guys can receive a
free $99 upgrade on your first project
this gets you I think a hundred and
thirty percent more submissions so
people who want to work with you and
give you first drafts of what you're
looking for
to access your free design please visit
99designs dot-com forward slash Tim and
click the link on the landing page
that's 99designs dot-com forward slash
Tim this podcast is brought to you by me
undies which I'm wearing right now have
you ever wanted to be as powerful as a
mullet wearing ninja from the 80s or a
sleek as a black panther in the Amazon
of course you have and that is where my
undies comes in I have spent the last
year wearing underwear from these guys
24/7 and they are the softest most
comfortable most colorful underwear I
have ever owned and it says here in the
copy they want a seasonality hook and
this is quote the summer and fall are
the perfect time to update your
underwear drawer end quote now I don't
know why the summer and fall are
specifically true for that but I would
say this that when you look in your
underwear drawer in your underwear wall
very often you'll see some that are a
little ragged
you know the bands are just a little
loose they tend to Sag where they
shouldn't sag that's disgusting
the undies are designed in LA and made
from sustainably sourced micro Modell a
fabric three times softer than cotton
even better me Andes has three different
subscription plans so you'll never get
bored with the ever-changing selection
and it includes free shipping there are
many reasons that me Andes has sold more
than 5 million pairs to date if you
don't love your first pair they'll give
you a new pair or a refund so to get 20%
off your first pair Plus free shipping
go to me undies comm board slash to him
that's me undies comm forward slash Tim
they're also undies for the ladies not
just dudes and lots of hot pics so check
it out me uneasy calm forward slash Tim